hi and welcome to my video series of
piyo techniques explained in five
minutes where I explain a concept in
biology in less than five minutes or so
if you haven't yet subscribed to my
channel hit that subscribe button and
please leave your comments below such
that it gives me positive motivation to
make more videos today's installment
we'll be talking about 2d gel
electrophoresis
as the name suggests don't mistake it by
unthinking that 2d means like two
dimension yeah it is two dimensional gel
electrophoresis but here two dimension
means two parameters so we already
learned about SDS page which we can tell
as a one dimension electrophoresis or by
saying that it's the separation is based
on one parameter and the first dimension
is the separation based on molecular
weight now there are certain problems
with one dimensional gel electrophoresis
let's say we in in the last protocol in
SDS page electrophoresis what we did is
like we stain the gel and we know our
protein of interest is let's say 75 kilo
Dalton and we expect that our protein of
interest to be present in that band but
imagine there could be other proteins
which have very similar molecular
weights so our band which we are seeing
at 75 kilo Dalton might not be a pure
band of 1 only one type of protein it
could be a well it could be a complex
band of having several type of proteins
right so we need a second parameter
which can resolve this issue and make
the separation better and that is why we
can do a 2d gel electrophoresis but the
two dimension of this original
electrophoresis which are basically two
parameters are isoelectric focusing so
separation based on isoelectric point
and second separation based on molecular
weight just like the 1d gel
electrophoresis so what are the steps
let's try to understand the process step
by step and try to get the advantage of
this so in any protein sample there
could be proteins of several sizes and
also different type of proteins
would have different degree of charges
right so the separation would be on both
the parameters so let's talk about the
isoelectric point first so as we know
the isoelectric point is a particular pH
point where the protein has no net
mobility and the mobility of the protein
would be zero because protein would X
exists as a sweeter iron so the first
step is to load the samples on IPG strip
which is a chair having various pH
gradients so it has from cathode so from
anode to cathode it has a pH gradient
and one once we run this jail several
proteins as you can see in the screen
like the pink ones the blue ones and the
yellow ones which are having several
different type of the chart several
different type of charge would move and
ultimately concentrate in format of a
band so what we have in the beginning is
like several type of proteins of several
sizes and several charges so at the end
of these isoelectric focusing all the
proteins with similar kind of I select
isoelectric point would come together
and concentrate in format of a bag then
what we can do is take this IPG strip
and load it on to second gel and this is
the very similar to one dimension gel
electrophoresis and we would allow them
to separate on basis of their molecular
weight and at the end what we get is a
separation based on molecular weight but
we have two degrees of separation one we
got in the horizontal in the vertical
axis we have the separation along a
molecular weight whereas in the
horizontal axis we had the isoelectric
point based separation so the proteins
which might have same molecular weight
and concentrate in a format of a band in
a one dimensional gel electrophoresis
they might be easily separated in two
dimensional gel electrophoresis for
further analysis from this point a spot
on the two dimensional gel can be
dissected taken out purified and we can
run a mass spec on that
understanding better for better
understanding its interactor or with its
purity I hope you enjoyed this video if
you like this video give it a big thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe